Thank you so much
for being here.
-Good to see you, man.
-I'm so happy to see you.
I'm so excited about this.
People are going to freak out.
It's so good.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Before we get into this,
you just wrapped your tour.
It's called
"The Unfortunate Return
of the Ridiculously
Self-Indulgent
Ill-Advised Vanity Tour."
-Yes.
-But you just wrapped up
at Carnegie Hall.
-Yes, oh, my goodness.
-What was that like?
-So emotional.
-I mean, it was a six-month tour
ending at Carnegie Hall
just this last Saturday night.
And the whole six months
I'm a little nervous.
You know, I'm kind of
freaked out, 'cause, you know,
Carnegie Hall, one of the most
prestigious venues in the world.
-Yeah.
-Bucket-list item for me.
So the whole six months
I'm like,
"Got to get ready
for Carnegie Hall."
-Yeah.
-And we get next to the --
A couple days before,
I'm just starting to freak out.
And then the day of the show,
I'm thinking,
"Okay, I've just done 128 shows.
It's just another show.
It's just another show."
And then I get
inside the building,
and I walk down the hall
to the dressing room,
and there's giant pictures of,
you know, Judy Garland
and Frank Sinatra
and The Beatles.
And my brain starts screaming,
"I don't belong here!
I don't belong here!"
-"I don't belong here at all."
Oh, my gosh.
-It went great, it went great.
-Questlove was there
and actually said it was one of
the best shows he's ever seen.
-Oh, thank you.
-Yeah, it was amazing.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've been talking about this
with different people
that have been in the movie
and made cameos in the movie.
And Daniel Radcliffe was here.
But I want to talk about this.
This is "Weird:
The Al Yankovic Story."
It is a biopic about your life.
-Yes.
100% accurate.
-Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
It is gating rave, rave,
rave reviews on this.
It's clever.
It's musical.
It's smart.
It's funny, obviously.
But let me set the tone
for the movie.
Right, this will set the tone.
-Okay.
-This is log line.
"Daniel Radcliffe
is Weird Al Yankovic
in the unexaggerated true story
about the greatest musician
and sex symbol of our time."
-Yes.
-That's the log line.
-That pretty much wraps it up.
-That wraps it up there, yeah.
How does the idea of a biopic
come to you?
Did you think
you would ever do this?
-It came from Eric Appel,
who directed the movie.
-Fantastic job, by the way.
-Amazing. His first feature.
-He crushed this one.
-Yeah.
But he directed the original
Funny or Die video
that this is based on,
which he did in 2010,
so this is 12 years
in the making.
And the original video basically
is sort of like the --
you know, where the whole thing
sprang from.
Aaron Paul starred in
the original version of me.
And Olivia Wilde played Madonna.
But we thought --
at the time, it was like,
"Oh, this is
a funny little video."
And it went viral.
And I play it in my live shows.
And everybody was like,
"When is the movie coming out?"
And I'd say, "It's just a gag.
It's just a joke."
But then after nine years
of that,
I said,
"Maybe we should do a movie."
-Yeah.
-So we did. Yeah.
-I mean, it's unbelievable.
Did you know
it was Daniel Radcliffe
was gonna be the person
to play you?
-He was our number-one choice.
And, yeah, I mean,
even though Daniel --
I think he said on your show
last night,
he's not an exact physical
doppelganger for me.
There's not a huge
physical resemblance there.
-No, you look
completely different.
-Well, yeah, kind of.
But we just felt like
he had the right energy.
You know, and we thought
maybe he'd go for it
'cause famously, after
the "Harry Potter" series,
he's chosen a lot of --
I'm not going to say weird,
but a lot of different,
you know, kind of --
He played a flatulent corpse
and a guy that grows horns
out of his head.
Maybe he could be Weird Al.
-Yeah, he does
make great choices.
-And also,
he's got the right energy
and the right attitude
and the chops.
I mean, he does --
he's great at comedy.
He's great at drama.
And we want--
It's obviously a comedy,
but we wanted it --
We didn't want it to play
like a comedy.
We wanted to play
like a very serious,
you know, Oscar-bait
Hollywood biopic.
-Yeah, maybe that's what's
so brilliant about it.
He plays it so serious
and perfectly funny,
but, I mean, he's a good actor
and good chops.
And Evan Rachel Wood, by
the way, plays Madonna in this.
And I'm telling you guys,
you're going to freak out.
She's unbelievable.
-I'm so sad that
we didn't have her sing.
'Cause when she came
on your show and sang Madonna,
Eric and I were both, like,
watching the show going,
"Why didn't we have her sing
in the movie?"
-Yeah, she doesn't sing in --
Yeah, exactly.
-But Daniel was saying,
"We also couldn't afford
any Madonna songs."
-True, true.
-Yeah, yeah.
But you know what was funny?
There was a --
You posted this.
There's actually
a Google search.
You said, "It amuses me
to no end that this is currently
the number-three Google search
under my name."
If you search "Weird Al," number
three is Weird Al and Madonna.
-Yeah, because on the trailer,
which had just come out,
it's obvious that
there's something going on
with me and Madonna,
so everybody was like,
"Did that really happen?
Did Weird Al and Madonna
have a thing?"
-Yeah, what was the story
with Madonna?
What part is truth,
or do you want to say?
-Well, there are a few
little nuggets of truth
sprinkled throughout the biopic.
The only time we actually --
Our relationship is platonic,
by the way.
The only time I actually met her
was in 1985.
I talked to her for maybe
like 45 seconds backstage.
So that's the extent
of the relationship.
-And she's in the whole movie.
-Oh, she's a huge part
of the movie.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's so good.
It's so good.
Another thing I loved about it,
and this is, I know, true
'cause I'm a superfan
of Weird Al,
is the Yankovic bump is what
they call it in the business.
If Weird Al does a parody
of your song,
your actual sales go up.
-That's an actual thing.
-That is true.
-So we use that in the movie,
as well,
but, of course,
we exaggerate it a bit.
Madonna sort of becomes like
the "villain" in the movie.
She, like, does everything
she can to calculatedly get me
to do a parody of her new single
so she can get
that Yankovic bump, you know.
-But it happened with Nirvana.
-Nirvana, yeah.
In fact, after my "Smells Like
Nirvana" parody came out,
we got a phone call from
Nirvana's record label saying,
"Thank you.
Because of your parody, we just
sold an extra million units
of 'Nevermind.'"
-A million units
because of your --
-Yeah, that's what he said,
yeah.
[ Applause ]
-And I think Kurt got
the phone call in this building.
-At "Saturday Night Live," yeah.
-"Saturday Night Live," yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause we couldn't
track down the right people
from his record label
to get the blessing.
And finally I was like,
"I'm just going to call him
on the set
of 'Saturday Night Live.'"
And he picked up the phone.
It's an old story, but basically
I said I wanted to do a parody.
And he said, "It's going to be
about food?"
I said, "No, it's about how
nobody can understand
your lyrics,"
and he went, "Great."
-He loved it.
The soundtrack, by the way,
is massive.
This is an amazing soundtrack.
46 songs?
-Well, it's not all me.
It's the whole orchestral score.
And it's a bunch
of re-recorded parodies.
I got to re-record,
"Another One Rides the Bus,"
"My Bologna,"
"I Love Rocky Road"
and "Amish Paradise"
and "Like a Surgeon."
So it was weird to go back
into the studio
like 40 years later...
-And do it again?
-...and do it again, yeah.
-But how much -- I mean,
how much music is this?
It's a lot of music.
-It's 78 minutes and 17 seconds.
-Gosh.
I mean, I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't say this just to say it,
but I love the movie so much,
and all -- when you see it,
you're going to --
I think there's awards buzz
around this movie.
That would be fantastic to see.
-I hope I get a Razzie.
-No, no, not a Razzie.
I'm telling you, man,
it's so well done.
You're in the movie.
Can you tell everyone
who you play?
'Cause you're not --
Clearly you are Weird Al,
but you can't play Weird Al.
-I sort of play the same part
that I played in the original
Funny or Die video.
I play the president
of my record label
who turns Weird Al down
in the movie.
-Yeah, and Will Forte
is in this scene, as well.
-Yes, indeed.
-Man, he's unbelievably funny.
-Amazing.
-There's so many cameos in this.
And every like three seconds,
you'll see somebody else.
You're like, "What?
Oh, my gosh."
Legend upon legend.
It's just so enjoyable and fun,
and I want to
show everyone a clip.
Here's Weird Al Yankovic in
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story."
Take a look.
Look, kid, if you really
have your heart set
on doing this stupid music,
maybe write more than one song.
-Yeah, all the biggest
musical acts
have more than one song
in their catalogue.
-That's very true.
And also, get out in front
of a live audience.
Any audience, any stage,
just get out there,
build up your chops,
and who knows?
Maybe someday we'll talk again.
-But don't count on it,
because you truly suck.
-Right.
-Okay.
-That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't wait.
You know I love you.
You're one of my favorites.
-Thank you.
-Weird Al Yankovic, everybody.
"Weird: The Al Yankovic Story"
is available for free
exclusively on The Roku Channel
this Friday.